dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
きょうは久しぶりに前について話したいと思う知ってる人もいると思う
禅の教えの中に公安っていうものが公安とは日常的思考を超えた世界に修行者に導く
ための課題のことだ
観月乳頭刺激
的な質問だよ例えば石州の声ありその声を聞けん
こういうのを考えることによって悟りに近づくそうだ
僕は個人的に公安がとても好きなので今日は現代社会と日本社会に基づいたオリジナル
コーンいくつか紹介したいと思っ
母から
ティファニーはロールを想像しろ
よし
次にテキサスロールを創造資料
ネットがない状態それともネットが遅い状態
ミュー机をもうにしたらどうなる自分のことを右にスワイプするセ電がない生活を想像
しろ
ローソンとファミマもない生活を想像しがツイートの桃澤いくら
babymetal が自分で曲を作ったらどうなヒップスターがヒゲを剃っても
ヒップスター官能主義は売れるのか
それとも僕は単なる馬鹿なのか
中以外ネット flex とできるコードがある one ok rock と付バス
ていくの違いは何
はさりって武器僕がんで不足なのか
あそれともどこかで悟空ば元気玉を作っているのか
普通の写真はすべていう風 meme は岩でできているのか
それと思う元は生むちぇりーがうるさいというイメージカールがそもそも静かな
ビーガンて計算に入る youtube が存在していなかったらあなたはこの2分を
どう過ごしていた
ごめん youtube と xperia 柄存在していなかったらあなたはこの2
分をどう過ごしていた
うん
ni